hey it's that time hey folks we are
rapidly coming to the end of 2019 and I
am going to do my pick for the 10 best
in my opinion films of the year
now I debated possibly doing this a
little bit later but I want to drop it
now like trying to get back on top of my
schedule there are a few things that I
wanted to see that I didn't I didn't get
around to but I don't don't have time to
cram them and now I'm not gonna delay
this list in order to do it so a couple
of things obviously only gonna talk
about movies that I have actually seen
my having actually made a video
reviewing these movies is not a
requirement to be on this list because
some movies I didn't get to until
significantly after they came out but if
I like them went up they're still gonna
be on this list so some of these this
will be the first time you're hearing me
actually talk about them on this channel
I think that's about it
like I said there are some movies that I
that I didn't get around to I wanted to
see John wick 3 I didn't get to it once
upon a time in Hollywood I wanted to get
to the Irishman I wanted to get to and I
still plan to watch those but like I
said I'm not gonna cram them in before
trying to get this video out so let us
start well actually even before we do
can I just be honest it wasn't a great
year for movies that's not to say there
were no good movies but there's multiple
films basically the bottom three of
these in a better year would not have
cracked the top 10 and coming out of all
three of them
I didn't think oh yeah that'll be on my
best to the end of the year list so I
don't want that to undercut the fact
that these were good movies there were
good movies that didn't even make the
list at all but when I found myself
compiling this list top have like good
stuff middle solid and then what sounded
the bottom is like really that's gonna
be in my top 10 and then I look at
everything I saw this here I'm like yeah
I guess so huh
okay so here we go now
ten Shazam this is a recent watch
because I missed it when it was in
theaters and it's very good it's very
good at what it is aiming to be which is
light and fun and enjoyable and funny
and great family entertainment which is
just nice to see because even marvel at
this point as much as it is certainly it
has tended to be lighter in tone than a
lot of the DC stuff or at least the
earlier parts of the DC things that it's
the beta beware or not the Marvel movies
have really been truly family movies
they're movies that younger people can
enjoy but they haven't really been
targeted at more that age range Shazam
is flat out and I'm really glad it
exists it takes the bottom slot because
some of the nature of some of the humor
because of the age range that and the
family audience it's targeted at leans a
little bit into sort of the cringe area
which isn't my favourite thing but it's
very good at what's what is trying to do
even if what it's trying to do is not my
own personal preference I'm super glad
this movie exists I'm really glad this
movie was successful and when is good
it's great the cast are clearly all
having fun and sort of what happens at
the very end for the for the climax that
that was that was stand up and Cheer
stuff good movie number 9 is a movie
that I really wanted to put higher but I
kind of can't I've got too many issues
with it but still good stuff How to
Train Your Dragon the hidden world this
is the third one I loved the original
the second one was amazing
this one is good which does make it a
step down relative to the other two when
it's good it's great that ending segment
especially holy crap mmm right in the
fields during the middle part of it like
the villains not great and some of it
feels like some of the characters don't
actually have a ton to do but they're
still there anyway which is a fairly
standard sequel problem but
when it is good at its best it reminds
me why I love this franchise and that is
enough to land it on the list
now number eight here's a big shock for
me I would not have called that this was
gonna be on my year-end list and I'm not
I'm not gonna claim it's any great movie
but I had a lot of fun with it it's also
one of those movies that kind of gets
elevated because of how much my daughter
enjoyed it which has happened before a
few times and that is detective Pikachu
yeah my kid is now very into Pokemon and
it is pretty much solely because of this
film she was aware of Pokemon before
this but it wasn't something she was
super into she's really into it now and
this got her there Ryan Reynolds voicing
Pikachu is so weird and bizarre yet
somehow perfect basically doing PG
Deadpool and I that shouldn't work but
it does the way they're visualized is
great because they're given sort of the
texture of something more realistic but
the designs aren't drastically changed
the designs of the Pokemon are all true
to what people love about this franchise
and love about the designs of these
characters and these creatures so it
retains the heart of that really well
and also just does a really great job of
making the world feel fun like you just
want to spend more time there I'm not
sure that detective Pikachu itself
really needs or demands or could even
necessarily justify a sequel but I would
be totally game to see other films set
in this world I want to spend more time
here and that was a fun thing to to
realize that yeah I'm totally game to
come back for more of this moving up
number seven Captain Marvel this is one
of those movies a little bit like Shazam
I am super happy that it was successful
I think it does what it sets out to do
really really well it didn't can always
connect with me all the way through as
much as I would have liked it to but I
can certainly see where
with some audiences it connected hard
and was exactly what they wanted part of
the thing is despite being a 90's kid
I'm not super nostalgic for the 90s so
90s Stahl juh is actually not an easy
way to my heart so maybe part of it is
that for me and then you know there's
there's other little things about it but
I tell you what brie Larson I think does
a great job Samuel Jackson is clearly
having a total blast and that final
confrontation the way things go down
between her and Jude Law is just raw
gold love it but I'm actually gonna go
one spot above that for a female lead
arguably superhero style film that is
not as good a movie and is way Messier
but I liked more number 6 goes to Aleta
battle angel and this is on the strength
of how Robert Rodriguez was able to
visualize this world and the performance
of Aleta herself she is awesome
she is well realized visually and the
performance is stunning it is a really
hard needle to thread giving us a
character this powerful yet this naive
and still make them relatable and not
have them just be just some weird
I mean fetish object that kind of
character kind of comes up and longer
and anime a bit but it's just so
perfectly nailed here the way that she
is able to capture the wonder that she
feels and the way she's able to project
the emotions that she's feeling and you
buy that these feelings are as big for
her as they are being portrayed it is so
good the movie overall is decent it's
it's messy it's sloppy but it's got so
much heart and that heart is almost all
in the character of a leader herself and
that really does elevate the whole thing
if the rest had been more finely tuned
it could have been a male
but as it stands that central
performance and her as a character is so
good it does still bring the rest of it
up and it gets set number six moving
along
number five you knew it had to be on
here somewhere Avengers endgame how do
you pay off ten years of buildup how how
can you possibly deliver on ten years of
anticipation and not just like we've
been waiting for ten years but ten years
of continually building film over film
over field giving us infinity war and
having to follow up on that how how
could you possibly pay that off and not
have it feel like an anti-climax this
this is how and if you are not all in on
Marvel it's long and bloated and
indulgent that is fair but I'm all-in
I love the Marvel Cinematic Universe not
every movie is great there are some that
I don't even like that much but I am so
in for this universe these characters
this approach and I think this is such a
amazing closure for this phase of Marvel
and I know technically it's the end of
Phase three but like it is the closing
of the book of what started at all we're
you know where it's saying this is the
end for Tony Stark for Steve Rogers and
that a lot of stuff is coming to a close
and it feels earned while at the same
time closing it off it's setting up who
will still carry the torch the thing is
and I actually do like this movie but it
is x-men Days of Future past it is doing
the same thing that movie did but way
better and I even like Days of Future
past but this is effectively doing the
same thing bringing it into an era while
at the same time sort of setting up
people to continue the legacy they're
both doing the same thing this did it
better man
good number for a movie that I really
enjoyed I don't think I've talked about
really yet all on here and I also can't
even show you an image of because it was
released by Paramount and Paramount are
the biggest friggin jerks when it comes
to copyright issues on YouTube but I can
still tell you what it is Rocketman I
thought this would just be fun you know
I I didn't know going in that it was
actually a musical proper not just a
movie about Elton John but a movie using
Elton John's songs and having the
characters actually burst into song and
the telling of it I thought that would
be a cute gimmick and it is yet somehow
it elevates what is not an altogether
you know drastically different or
reinvention of the rock star rise to
fame story
it fits the template but having it be a
musical and and having it be a
well-constructed one the songs were
really well chosen really well performed
that makes all the difference because
the the worst kind of jukebox musical
you're across the universe's your mamma
mias while they can be fun the problem
with them is is they generally have a
very thin story that only exists to
justify the use of whatever the next
song is it's an excuse to get us from
song to song to song here it really does
feel like they sat down worked out what
parts of Elton John's life they were
going to tell and then one through is
kind of going what song would help tell
this part of that story better so it
doesn't feel like the narrative is just
connecting the musical numbers the
musical numbers feel like they're
elevating the story despite the fact
that the songs pre-exists the movie is
really well constructed and Taron
Egerton is great as Elton John there's a
really good movie and we will continue
up towards our top three but before we
do we're gonna pause
honorable mention and a couple of
dishonorable because I don't see enough
movies in a year to do a separate list
of the ten worst because you know this
isn't my living I don't see every movie
that comes out I don't try to see every
movie that comes out if I think I'm
really not gonna like something I just
flat-out won't watch it
so most movies that I suspect I would
really hate um I don't bother going to
see but I do have a couple of
dishonorable mentions to get to but
before that honorable mention goes to my
daughter's favorite movie of the year
which I did ask her and she is going
with frozen two didn't make my list but
she really really liked it dishonorable
z' for me okay so I've got to I need to
cover what I feel was the worst movie I
saw this year and my biggest
disappointment now biggest
disappointment this one hurt and it's
not even that it's a bad movie but for
how much I liked the one before and how
much I was anticipating this it was a
disappointment it was a step down and
that is spider-man far from home and
it's not a bad movie but spider-man
homecoming is consistently in my top
three MCU films you know personal
favorites and its sequel probably right
in the middle overall of twenty-some-odd
movies yeah that's a step down that was
a disappointment I suspect people who've
been watching my reviews lately might
think that worst movie I saw would go to
last Christmas didn't because like I did
actually get entertainment haha
and the way that was bad was just so
whoever thought this was a good idea no
the one that really ticked me off and I
knew I was gonna hate it and under
normal circumstances I wouldn't watched
it but I can't really wanted to see it
the Lion King
lord I can't reiterate this stuff see my
earlier review if you need to know but
let's get to top three number three a
movie that I did not think was going to
be good and I get to now hold up as an
illustration of I'm serious when I say I
love to be proven wrong early trailers
for this
I turned my nose up at I said this looks
terrible
I heard the very idea of this movie I'm
like this will be bad Toy Story 4 I
liked it when I saw it I was surprised
how much I liked it when I saw it and
the more I thought about it the more I
liked it I liked it because what I
assumed Toy Story 4 would be would be a
painful continuation you know very
ham-fisted forcing one more story out of
something that was very clearly closed
off in the third one but that's not what
toys are for is Toy Story 4 is a coda
the trilogy proper is still Toy Story 1
2 3 that is Andy's toys and what Toy
Story 4 is is that it's an indication of
what life can be after the life they
knew and you can argue that that was set
up with them you know becoming Bonnie's
toys at the end of Toy Story 3 but I
really only set them up for the same
cycle we saw with Andy Toy Story 4
through beau and eventually woody shows
us what can happen when you break that
cycle and that these characters have the
power to choose to exit that cycle and
for some of them that's the right choice
and it's just nice it is nice to see a
film aimed at a younger audience about
moving on to a new phase in your life
even if that means leaving behind
everything that you thought your life
was always going to be that ending is
not the end of your world there are new
things for you to find and in the scope
of this franchise overall I think this
is a fantastic final note I do hope
final I'm not sure they could keep going
out of this and it does end in a way
that I like
I think definitively they are now done
but it was really good number two here's
another one I have not talked about
before because I only watched it
recently us wow man I I had high hopes
for this one because get out
Jordan peels previous film was I said
the best film of that year when it came
out and this had high expectations on it
it did not let me down and the thing is
it rides such a fine line because it
comes dangerously close to breaking what
is for me a rule of allegorical
metaphorical and message filmmaking
which is that if it only works if you
have been told what the allegory is what
the metaphor means and it doesn't work
as a story in and of itself then it
doesn't work properly at least I feel
that and this comes really close because
see the film in and of itself the first
time I got to the end I wasn't totally
sure I understood what I had just
watched and it took some looking into
some of the writings about it some of
the things that Jordan Peele himself
said about it to make me understand what
the film was actually doing and once I
did it was like oh but see that's the
thing first of all even before that even
when I wasn't sure I knew what it was
about it was still an amazing visceral
experience to watch while I could not
necessarily say what it was it left me
with a satisfying experience even if a
slightly befuddled one even before I
knew what all the things going on with
it were
and once I knew it was the best kind of
learning about the intentions of the
film cuz I mean you go oh well that
means this connects to this and all this
stuff fits together
oh yeah because the worst kind of
allegorical filmmaking is when you find
out what the allegory is here you go
okay wait but if that's that then why is
this this and that doesn't fit together
is it make any sense US huh first of all
I actually recommend you if you haven't
seen it yet watch it without reading
anything about it
experience it viscerally then start
digging into the thoughts and the
dissections and the analyses of it oh
man this thing is so densely layered
with thematic meaning it's amazing we
just actually a feature it shares with
my number one pick and I'm not gonna
spend a ton of time dwelling on what the
number one pick is because I think it's
gonna confuse enough people that I need
to devote an entire video to explaining
why it's in the number one spot and that
video is actually going to happen in a
week but for right now my number one
film of 2019 is the lego movie 2 the
second part I'm not kidding
I think this film has been unfairly
forgotten I think it has been unfairly
marked as a lesser sequel to the early
films I think that's wrong I think this
film is amazing and touching and
thematically dense and very carefully
woven the theming into the way
everything is presented and it all links
up and it is terrifically constructed
and like I said I feel like enough
people are gonna go what that yeah I'm
devoting a full video to explaining that
to back in in a week to find out the
details on that but for right now just
know it is my pick for the best movie of
2019 what are your thoughts on this list
what are your top picks whatever your
thoughts are drop something down the
comments let's talk about it stuff to do
as well
like subscribe support me on patreon
that is super appreciated share this
video around any and all those things
awesome stuff I've got links for other
things down there besides social media I
wrote a book I've got a pedo box
whatever you want to do but you also
don't have to do any of it because at
the end of the day you're the council
I'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council is
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]